[Music]
Farming is ancient. Humans and earth
working closely together. Our hands have
long known the soft soil. The sun has
warmed countless generations of farmers.
This connection to the land is deep.
Growing food is a fundamental human act.
It has sustained humanity for millennia.
Yet, this traditional path is undeniably
hard. Long hours under a blazing sun or
freezing cold. The work is often
backbreaking and repetitive. Farmers
face nature's unpredictable whims.
Droughts can parch the land. Floods can
destroy hope. It is a life of constant
toil and uncertainty. We look to the
stars above. Science and technology are
our most powerful tools. Can these tools
ease the farmer's burden? Can they help
us nurture our planet better? A new dawn
for farming may be approaching.
Technology offers fresh eyes and new
methods. It promises to change farming
for the better. This is about enhancing
tradition, making it stronger and
sustainable for our future. Let us now
explore this exciting new agricultural
frontier.
Think of the sheer physical effort
involved. Day after day, the labor
remains immense. Tilling hard soil,
planting seeds, pulling weeds, carrying
heavy loads of harvested crops. This
work shapes the land and wears down the
body. Nature is a powerful force.
Farmers depend on its cooperation, but
the weather is unpredictable. A sudden
frost can kill young plants. Too little
rain brings drought. Too much rain
floods fields. These chances create
constant worry. A year's work can vanish
quickly. Our planet's resources are
precious. Water is essential.
Traditional farming sometimes uses them
inefficiently. Water might be spread too
widely. Fertilizers can be used in
excess. This can harm the soil and
nearby rivers. We must be wiser
stewards. Protecting our earth is vital.
Our human family is growing. Feeding
billions requires innovation. We need to
grow more food sustainably. Technology
can help us meet this
challenge. Imagine if our plants could
talk to us. Smart irrigation makes this
vision almost a reality. Tiny sensors
act as ears in the soil. They monitor
moisture levels. This information is key
to efficient farming. The sensors
collect data about water. This data
travels wirelessly to a central
computer. The computer analyzes the
information. It decides the optimal time
to water and how much water each plant
requires. No more guesswork, just
precision and efficiency. The benefits
are remarkable. We can save enormous
amounts of water. Plants receive exactly
what they need. This leads to healthier,
stronger plants. They grow better and
produce more. It is a win for the farmer
and the planet. Picture fertile fields
flourishing using less water than
before. This technology transforms
farming. Farmers become guardians of
water resources. They can grow more food
with less impact. This is a smart path
forward, respecting our planet's
precious water resources. A new way to
cultivate
[Music]
life. Look up towards the sky. A new
helper is there. Drones are small
unmanned aircraft. They are the modern
farmer's powerful eyes soaring high
above the fields. They see things humans
cannot. Like scouts, they explore the
land. They map the agricultural universe
below, gathering vital data for the
farmer. Drones carry high resolution
cameras. They take detailed pictures of
crops. They can spot early signs of
trouble. Perhaps some plants are sick or
need water. Drones can spray nutrients
or pest control. With pinpoint
precision, this keeps crops healthy and
thriving. Automation extends beyond the
sky. Imagine tractors that drive
themselves. Guided by GPS signals,
robotic machines can plant seeds and
harvest. They work tirelessly day or
night. This eases traditional labor,
freeing farmers for other tasks. This is
about empowering people, humans, and
machines working
together. Imagine drawing long lines
across the earth's surface, perfectly
straight lines guided from outer space.
This is what GPS technology offers to
farmers. GPS means global positioning
system. A network of satellites. These
satellites orbit our planet. They send
precise signals to us. These signals
help us know our exact location. This
power reshapes our fields. Modern
tractors have GPS receivers. They listen
to satellite signals. The tractor
follows a pre-planned path. Seeds are
placed in the soil at the exact depth
and spacing. No more guesswork. Every
seed gets its ideal place. Optimal
spacing means each plant has room to
grow. This results in healthier crops.
Crop yields increase. Tractors use less
fuel, reducing waste and saving
resources. Farming with this accuracy is
revolutionary. It ensures the best
possible
harvest. Remember the old farmer's
almanac? Full of wisdom and the farmer's
trusty notebook filled with
observations. Now imagine these tools
supercharged, fully digitized. Farm
monitoring apps bring all information
together. Data streams in from soil
sensors, from drones, from weather
satellites. It all flows into one
central place, available in the farmer's
hand. Farmers can check soil moisture
levels instantly. See local weather
forecasts, monitor crop health remotely,
track market prices for produce, all
from a smartphone or tablet. Important
decisions can be made quickly. The
improvements are real and measurable.
Fields watered with smart systems boost
yields. Drones detecting pests early
save crops. GPS guided tractors save
fuel. Less water is used. Less
fertilizer wasted. These changes make a
big difference. Data transforms farming
from intuition to science. The results
are bigger harvests, more sustainable
methods, a resilient food supply for
everyone. New technologies come with an
initial cost. An upfront investment is
needed. Smart irrigation systems,
advanced drones, GPS guided tractors.
These tools require financial resources.
This can seem like a big step,
especially for smaller family farms. We
must acknowledge this economic reality,
but consider the long-term value, the
future gains. Savings in water can be
substantial. Less fuel is burned, less
fertilizer is bought. Increased crop
yields mean more income. Over time,
benefits outweigh costs. It is an
investment in a productive future. We
must be open to new ideas, new ways.
These technologies are like new
telescopes. They help us see Earth
differently to understand its needs
deeply. The future of farming is
arriving. A blend of ancient wisdom and
modern technology.